ilan est donc l etat mais will hahn il
n'est pas bien il retourne à l'école il
est retourné à l'école louis pas à la
cantine à l'aube dimanche chez vous
actuellement l'ol à cet accord ils se
sentent démunis il 60 unis alors qu'il
n'a rien fait que la faute fière de moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce jeune de 19 ans qui a été condamné
pour trafic de stupéfiants et donc la
mer va être expulsé de son logement hlm
est ce que vous comprenez sa réalité
c'est quoi c'est certainement une pauvre
dame qui est dans une cité qui est
peut-être femme de ménage qui a du mal à
joindre les deux bouts elle peut pas pu
s'occuper de son gamin avait pas tout le
temps derrière lui c'est difficile c'est
une ville très compliqué ok donc oui
effectivement effet elle peut pas être
responsable de ce gamin qui est en
perdition qui est un échec scolaire elle
n'a pas d'argent bon voilà c'est ça moi
je comprends l'argument qui a été donné
il ya un instant c'est à dire c'est une
mère seule une famille monoparentale qui
galèrent et ça ira et qui se retrouve
face à un fils même qui peut aller en
disant ça mais pour moi c'est lyon qui
fait un mètre quatre-vingt kita molosses
et qu'elle peut et qu'elle peut pas
tenir tout à fait mais dans ce cas là
l'état doit la priver de son éducation
parents parental mettre ce jeune dans
une maison de redressement raison des
faits en fonction de la gravité des
faits et à ce moment là effectivement on
règle comme ça
merci thomas d'être là votre mère a été
expulsé est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter ce qui s'est passé dans cette
affaire
c'est qu'ils n'ont procédé
dégradation des actes de vandalisme on
parle de travailler ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que
j'avais déjà fait des gens c'est vrai
quand j'étais mineure c'est vrai que
j'ai fait deux trois bêtises donc on on
habite dans un hlm c'est vrai que ça
justifie pas mais
moi très tôt
avant le bac ce genre de télé cox avait
relevé des problèmes de santé dont ils
sont dénoncés dans les souvenirs aux
besoins de ma famille de ma mère surtout
bien sûr bien sûr qu'il n'est pas du
tout d'accord je comprends pas comment
ils mercurio
est encore avec thomas thomas burstyn
des cheveux je vous ai dit voilà une
maman je suis désolé qu'est ce qu'on
vient v10
bien sûr bien sûr je suis terriblement
désolé je trouve que c'est scandaleux
moi je trouve que moi j'ai été punie
comme à montreuil le trafic que gekko
mais je suis sous bracelet électronique
j'ai pris 20 mois dont dix de siouxie
10e en aménagement avec je crois
chronique donc je repars pourquoi mr de
rationner de mes actes
surtout que moi je disais déjà assumé je
suis en train de payer le trafic de
stupéfiants il a toujours existé d année
en année de famille en famille
voilà si on devrait vraiment viré tout
le monde parce que leurs enfants
graphique et un jour on s'en sortirait
pas
complice de maisons avant si je fais des
actes c'est moi même bien y regarder
j'en paie le prix aujourd'hui et surtout
car après tout ça j'ai quitté le
domicile de m donc je comprends pas vous
pouvez même envoyer les
gens peuvent pas comprendre t'inquiète
bien sûr chine qui
la semaine dernière dans un petit
village de gironde un enfant de 7 ans
était raccompagné chez lui par la police
c'est la faire de ce week end on en a
parlé pour l'empêcher de manger à la
cantine sous la mère de famille ne
conteste pas les faits elle doit bien
800 euros à la cantine scolaire
de l'euro toutes les personnes qu'on a
contacté se sont engagés à faire des
règlements
ce qui se passe de chez vous je suis
chez moi ouais je suis à ma fenêtre je
vois le policier on vous avait prévenu
avant à non pas du tout non personne
vous appelez de l'école pour vous dire à
ceux ci n'ont jamais redit que si
pourtant on dit qu'on vous appelez que
vous avez dit que vous pouvez pas
ce que mon fils a des rendez vous
l'après midi donc j'ai parlé le matin
même avec la maîtresse qu'est la
directrice je lui dis je récupère et wi
lan comme tous les jeudis en fait après
la cantine non non pas du tout d'accord
et donc là vous êtes chez vous et je le
vois passer à l'issue du coucou on le
voit tous les matins il est très gentil
le policier oui j'aurai un petit garçon
avec moi je sais pas
et là je le vois surgir de la voiture et
courir jusqu'à et bella je suis choqué
alors je leur demande pourquoi vous avez
ramené mon fils voilà c'est ça qu'est ce
qui se passe alors il lui explique que
c'est passé comme ça lui il exécute les
ordres / dollar associés l'école a
appelé la police pour ramener le petit
oui danois l'a vu que sa mère ne paie
pas
on va aller le chercher devant toute
l'école devant tous les copains et ça
allait bien sale p on va les chercher
vous venez de la cour pour le ramener
chez lui pour un malpropre ton équipe
comment il a vécu wi lan call qu'est ce
qui vous a dit willan il était vraiment
il est rentré vous explique tout vent
s'est moqué de moi on m'a déjà là l'an
prison angib.ul tu n'as rien fait n'est
pas ta faute l'histoire à elle par deux
mois à la base ça tu es pas fautif c'est
pas grave vous en êtes voulu de ce qui
lui arrivait pas ben oui bien sûr
évidemment a bien sûr parce que alors
oui l'année les dons qu'elle est un
mérou ilan il n'est pas bien il retourne
à l'école il la retourne à l'école louis
pas à la cantine a donc dimanche chez
vous actuellement l'ue a lancé ces
accords qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit c'est
ses petits camarades mais ils ont par
rapport à l'histoire ballon
ils ont ils leur expliquer ce qui s'est
passé je sais c'est pas un grand bavard
c'est pas un centime aux noms revenaient
sachez qu'on parle de cette histoire qui
a fait énormément parler ce week-end le
petit wydad qui a été ramené par la
police chez lui parce que sa maman
n'avait pas payé la cantine ils se
rendirent unis ils se sentent qu unis
alors qu'il n'a rien fait que la faute
vient de moi il se sent puni vous en
êtes vous lui de voile assure évidemment
évidemment à voir c'est les choses avant
et je vais vous dire on va s'occuper de
cette dette de cantine comme ça au moins
ce sera fait pendant ta nou avec la
production va s'occuper de cette dette
de cantine donc c'est on va la prendre
en charge
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment ça va alors non non ouais
bon vous avez dit t'inquiète pas je sais
que répondre de la flotte et comme tout
le monde me dit on est désolé ça on est
désolé exemple je vous déteste pas
d'accord est probant dans l'électrique à
la musique
[Musique]
up in toigo jeter mais pourquoi là pomme
et c'est gratuit [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
je te merde
[Rires]
quand vous êtes contrarier
genzyme
[Applaudissements]
forcément qu'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est quoi votre version des faits alors
la version des faits de la maman sur le
principe qu'elle doit de l'argent bien
sûr c'est indéniable mais en ce qui
concerne le fait qu'on soit allé
chercher
son fils à la cantine ça c'est pas du
tout passé comme il le dit à aucun
moment ça n'a été traumatisant pour
l'enfant parce qu'on lui a raconté une
histoire en fait on lui a dit que sa
maman avait oublié de dire qu'ils ne
mangeaient pas à la cantine et que comme
elle connaissait le policier municipal
qui assurent la sécurité des enfants à
midi le soir et le matin à la rentrée
elle lui avait demandé de
le ramener chez elle jusqu'à présent
personne ne savait que sa maman avait
une dette de cantine aujourd'hui le
monde entier sait qu'elle a une dette de
cantine donc forcément les petits
copains forcément les mamans et les
papas des autres enfants mais nous on
n'a pas traumatisé cet enfant et elle
m'a dit de toutes les façons si vous
n'acceptez pas mon enfant à la cantine
je ne paierai pas les 273 euros donc je
lui ai dit écoutez non c'est pas comme
ça que ça se passe vous payez votre
dette et je reprendrai votre enfant à la
cantine mais allez voir le trésor public
pour convenir d'un échéancier on ne
demande pas qu'elle paie 873 euros tout
de suite lg relance comme tout le monde
elle a eu des invitations à des
rendez-vous à la mairie pour essayer de
trouver une solution ensemble elle est
venue une fois en avril nous remettre un
rib mais qu'ils ne pouvaient pas être
utilisées pour les dettes antérieures ce
qu'elle nous a dit trésor public qui ce
cas vous a remis un rival a dit que vous
aviez vous l'aviez pas utilisé ah bah si
on l'a utilisé le premier prélèvement
qu'on a fait il a été rejeté un bal
d'accord entre vous elle ne devait pas
inscrire l'enfant à la cantine je veux
dire aujourd'hui c'est la collectivité
qui supporte la charge des impayés et
des gens qui sont malveillants mais tout
d'un coup on a une autre version on a
une femme qui n'a pas payé qui n'a pas
voulu trouver un arrangement qui n'a pas
ouvert son courrier qui a menacé en plus
de dire derrière eh ben il ira quand
même sinon de toute manière je paierai
pas si vous voulez publier soi et qui
vient ensuite se plaindre à la
télévision pardon ces
[Musique]
images vous cautionnez ou pas
quand je vois les moches de l'enfant
village oui sans plus ce sont plus des
liens c'est à dire je sais pas si je
vous assure ça vous désole parce qu'il
ya des gens qui se mariait tous acquis à
leur mariage les plus être cachée ou pas
du que les gens se marient wissing
peut-être mais que le maire soit en
farine et bon jeu ça ne me touche pas et
gucci il n'y a eu aucune arrestation n'a
aucune arrestation nous sommes même
parti on a salué le commissaire nous
avons des vidéos on a discuté avec le
commissaire nous sommes repartis comme
nous sommes venus oui non mais attendez
moi les les gens si vous voulez qu'ils
ont des propos antisémites qui sont des
races je vous invite à faire la demande
et rationaliste je vous invite encore
une fois c'est raté on en rajoute devant
des flics vous claveau claquer des
fesses devant les juifs 1 au nom
des spécialités nick quand vous dites
ont commencé moi finir je vous ai laissé
parler c'est votre vitalité d'un avis ni
joli conte n'est pas la présidente sa
marionnette pour parler d'eux est ce
aussi ses mythes se fondra si je ne peux
pas dire
qui a été multi condamné non mais la
rente coton qui passe à l'oeil arraché
sur la france non non non ce sont des
aides de la france
bien sûr
un égyptien comme à bruxelles
[Applaudissements]
c'est vous qui est à craindre
vous êtes français
[Musique]
je pense
qu'il ya salami l'ont reçu samedi soir
très tard puisqu'il ya une prime de
france 2 qui termine à 00h10 elle était
en direct et je pense que l'on reculé à
saddam et étaient un petit peu
près toujours le même je dis toujours la
même chose qui désespère certains ça
c'est vrai on peux pas vous le reprocher
à la gent temps la même chose depuis
plusieurs années au moins je ne me
contredis pas fait par exemple pour
laquelle à bout de cinq ans j'en ai mais
où je comprends bien j'anime aux hits et
elle qu' il n'y a pas eu on n'a même pas
su de quoi parler le livre ça a été
immédiatement des attaques personnelles
ensuite laurent a entièrement privatisé
le débat elle a été question de leur
audience il a été question de ce que dit
eric zemmour sur sa précédente visite
sur le sur le même plateau ça tournait
vraiment à quelque chose de personnel
duquel on était exclu ce risque de
commandement sur l'équipe de france et
sur les prénoms et noms français voilà
puisque eric zemmour a précisé que s'il
était élu s'il se présentait bien
entendu il prendrait des mesures fermes
notamment d'interdire les prénoms
musulmans en prénoms dits principal
regarde il nous est président j'aurais
tapis la loi de 1803 français n'a pas le
droit d'appeler son fils maintenant un
enfant qui s'appelle mohamed moi je
trouve que au bout de trois générations
c'était la troisième génération je
trouve ça triste il s'appelle encore
mohamed sont là précisément moi je
trouve qu'on voit ou pas cyril zemmour a
une stature d'homme d'état parce que
justement il reste dans ce côté
polémiste en fait il n'a pas de stature
d'homme d'état il est toujours en sa
fixette la france dans le caniveau si on
est dans le caniveau sa cause des
immigrés donc voilà donc il ressort son
éternel manège et je trouve que
justement est requis et es-salaam et ont
bien fait le job parce que justement ils
ont piégé ils ont montré aux quêtes et
polémiste au mieux sur une heure combien
de temps les débats à venir pour garoua
d'abord parce que zemmour est la
créature de ruquier il est sorti de son
ventre est donc retrouver le fils mais
pour toi le père j'ai vu moi ce qui est
sorti de mon ventre
la télé c'est pas une interview de
politis ou du monde d'eric zemmour c'est
le bordel c'est la mauvaise foi c'est
bien ici alors
mais c'est pour ça que j'aime venir
j'adore du direct à la fois découvrir de
la mauvaise foi et du spectacle qu'on a
encore le droit besoin 5,6 à sciences po
il ya trop de blancs et pourquoi on n'a
pas le droit d'interroger sur le nombre
de noirs en équipe de france de foot
pour nourrir l'équipe de france je
regrette le débat n'a pas été au niveau
il fallait que quelqu'un réponde à
zemmour pourquoi il ya autant de noirs
en équipe de france c'est qu'en france
le modèle de réussite qu'on propose aux
noirs c'est plus des footballeurs quatre
avocats ou médecins voilà
les effectifs à vis de lui répondre
quelque chose d'être argument contre
argument
on va avancer avec le sujet sur nabila
hier soir y avait un documentaire sur
tmc story sur la villa et on a découvert
l'immense fortune de nabila je ne sais
pas si vous faites des petits postes
instagram mais moi je peux vous le dire
je vais me mettre
sur le site selon le magazine voici la
star toucherait chaque mois pas moins de
quatre cent mille euros soit environ 4 8
millions d'euros par an contrairement à
nous on ne peut pas dire qu'elle perd
son top sur instagram
pour info les influences world iv télé
réalité issue date-là et ont la
réputation d' accepter tout et n'importe
quoi pour faire de l'argent il refuse
pas un contrat star qui choisissent les
marques par me anne marque de sextoys
qui les a contactés récemment ils ont
refusé donc ils prennent pas tous les
contrats ils sont hyper sélectifs et
avec ça ils réussissent à gagner
beaucoup d'argent donc franchement bravo
sur cinq six ans à ce juge 66 ans à 4000
euros par mois sans barbe
alors on a touché 2 millions pour un
truc d'amazon alors amazonie island il
ya un million d'exclusivité en plus ça
fait 2 millions comme 1,2 million de
2007 qui lui donnent
toujours marrer quand on a de l'argent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]